emmanuelle seigner bonsoir
vous connaissez tous le monde je connais
marc et je connais ce permis et ufolep à
10 la peste aussi on s'est croisé une
fois bon et emmanuel alors ça va on m'a
dit pas de dérapage on va essayer de ne
pas déraper laurent est ce que tu peux
essayer c'est le genre de la maison mais
ce qui m'a déjà vu déraper ici thierry
je pose mon nom mais bon je te le dis il
faut pas dérapé ce soir leur insu voilà
c'est tout tu as bien plomber l'ambiance
aussi alors il annuel signé on vous a vu
dans détective de jean luc godard ça
dérape non c'est non à la moi je sens
que c'est à dire alors qu'elle frantic
de roman polanski lune de fiel de roanne
polanski place vendôme de nicole garcia
ils se marièrent et eurent beaucoup
d'enfants de yvan attal et on vous
retrouve aujourd'hui dans backstage
d'emmanuelle bercot avec isild le besco
noémie lvovsky samuel benchetrit et
valéry zeitoun
alors le pitch ça te dérange que je
fasse mon fils va faire un bras de fer
c'est un enfant
le pitch est une fable sur la perversité
de la relation entre les stars et les
fans justement c'est l'histoire de lucie
interprété par isild le besco une jeune
lycéenne qui vit seul avec sa mère et
son jeune frère sa mère est une espèce
de femmes professionnelles mais pour lui
si il y en a qu'une c'est vous c'est à
dire lorraine dans le film qui est une
chanteuse à succès un peu dans l'esprit
de de mylène farmer alors sa mère va
organiser une rencontre entre sa fille
lucy et lorraine vous lors d'une
émission télévisée qui s'appelle
backstage mais au moment de l'émission
la petite lucie perd tous ses moyens
face à son idole aucun son ne sort de sa
bouche elle déçue après le départ de son
idole et elle décide d'aller la
retrouver à paris et là se noue une
relation entre elle et vous qui est très
étonnante oui je pense que l a fait des
recherches mais aussi elle l'a fait de
manière très intuitive c'est pour ça que
c'est réussi alors pour vous
lawrence est un vrai personnage a créé
pour c'est une chanteuse donc il fallait
rendre cette chanteuse crédible et puis
et puis c'est un personnage qui est très
désespérée donc il y avait beaucoup de
travail à faire là dessus grande
fragilité oui effectivement alors au
départ elle hésite et la réalisatrice
emmanuelle bercot à vous proposer le
rôle en vous aussi vous hésitiez
d'ailleurs je pense qu'elle a vu
beaucoup d'actrices et ella ella ella a
fait passer des essais rats beaucoup
d'actrices parce qu'elle voulait
entendre la personne chanter et à et
j'ai obtenu le rouge je ne vais pas
devenir chanteuse sinon juste normal
qu'une comédienne je pense que ça se
chante et on appris de mon métier de
pouvoir chanter danser ouais voilà vous
sentez bien dans un rôle assez difficile
pour vous interprétez vous dit le soir
quand je rentrais chez moi je tremblais
c'est secouer jeter écorché c'est vrai
c'est vrai
en fait emmanuelle bercot elle a une
méthode elle veut elle veut vraiment
trouver l'essence chez celle est réelle
elle demande beaucoup de fins de
s'investir complètement en fait et donc
ça passe par des étapes qui sont pas
très facile si vous avez entamé
physiquement c'est en revanche beaucoup
d'abord mes cheveux il était tout blanc
et enfin et que j'ai des colleurs chaque
semaine donc à la fin du tournage une
petite crête cheveux coupés
j'avais beaucoup maigri enfin c'était
assez dur
au mal ouais tu allais contente je crois
que c'est la première fois que manuel
vient mais qu'elle est vraiment contente
d'être là c'est vrai c'est juste la
deuxième fois que je vais en fait ouais
ouais mais bon
mais la première fois c'est vrai que
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à travers
ta mère a été odieux
alors vous êtes inspiré vous vite de
marilyn de sa fragilité son tour de rôle
oui en fait je me suis inspiré des
derniers jours de marilyn il ya un dvd
qui est très bien fait là dessus où ils
disent que justement avec tous les
cachets qu'elle prenait l'alcool à
changer d'humeur tout le temps et
c'était vraiment le cas de lorraine dans
le scénario et ça m'a ça m'a donné la
clé en fait ouais vous auriez pu vous
inspirer de l'om parce qu'ils étaient
assez fragile aussi non je suis
vulnérables mais je suis quelqu'un de
très stable
côté terrien des saignées sway liger le
tabac très droit en faire une interview
oui non ce sera facile vous allez
répondre par oui ou par non d'accord tu
d'interviews oui non
vous êtes heureuse en ce moment est ce
que vous êtes une bonne mère
l'objet dire oui
ah oui est ce que vous êtes prêtes à
arrêter votre carrière si vos enfants
vous le demander
non on va revenir sur la question
précédente
pourquoi je pense pas que je pense pas
que c est une bonne marque faire tout ce
qu'ils veulent vous trouvez pas qu'on
vous voit un peu trop souvent nu au
cinéma oui
vous avez déjà eu recours à la chirurgie
esthétique
ça vous fait peur d'avoir 40 ans bientôt
déjà pris de la drogue oui
est ce que vous pensez être une bonne
comédienne oui excuse et déjà chopé la
grosse tête
non
excusez-nous
j'ai dit ça va sur la gueule je ne sors
ça va déraper la paix je vous ai tourné
déjà des films uniquement pour le pognon
est-ce que vous avez marre qu'on vous
parle de refaire tout le temps non vous
avez déjà eu envie de mourir oui
croyez en dieu non
vous donner aux gens qui font la manche
dans la rue oui il ya encore un fantasme
sexuel que vous n'avez pas réalisé oui
je crois qu'il ya quelque chose après la
mort à des propositions tiennent oui
je sais pas je parle rocher pas non
oui est ce que vous vous aimez oui
est-ce que vous m'aimez oui alors dit la
vérité
c'est vraiment plus
rien maintenant anovo un cabas oui c'est
nouveau maintenant on s'entend bien
voilà c'est comme ça est ce que vous
pourriez donner votre vie pour une
grande cause quelle jambe du causse où
l'appel génitales par exemple
est-ce que vous avez des tabous
à part le silence
est ce que vous auriez un flic
m'a gardé
est ce que vous méritez ce qui vous
arrive oui
est ce que vous aimez être connus dans
la rue
est ce que vous croyez la justice divine
est ce que vous croyez la justice des
hommes
est ce que vous allez réaliser vos rêves
d'enfants oui est-ce que vous pensez que
vos parents sont fiers de vous oui
est-ce que vous pensez que vos enfants
sont fiers de vous
oui
est-ce que vous avez menti depuis le
début cette interview tout le temps non
non j'ai pas menti alors pourrait pas
que ça dérape de l'autre côté et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux